to get going here we are leading up to
the big match between of course the st.
Louis chess club in the San Francisco
mechanics this is going to be a crazy 20
on 20 match it looks like the stream is
just getting set up here and we are
officially live okay so of course this
is going to be match between the st.
Louis chess club and a lot of local st.
Louis players a lot of local kids a lot
of local just regular old players are
going to be taking on like I said the
mechanics chess club all the way from
San Francisco so it looks like we have
just about five minutes here till we get
underway in those five minutes we're
just gonna hang out a little bit let the
people come in get ready for the big
match let's see if I can pull up our
roster here and see who we have got in
this match I'm just gonna do so right
here so of course we've had a couple
last-minute substitutions just to throw
our opponents off a little bit and to
make things a little bit more
interesting but more or less the
breakdown is we've got Erin ribbon ski
from the West
Webster team as well as the one and only
justice Williams on our team along with
Julie and pearl Aiko feed a master Talia
Cervantes those are more or less our top
rated players a lot of title players
Erin a great international master
justice a feed a master tally also feed
a master Julian a super strong national
master protest league hero for the st.
Louis Archbishop's meanwhile the
mechanics have own people nobody cares
about other famous faces on the st.
Louis team include Jonathan France Danny
Machuca the man in the shadows running a
lot of these videos and running a lot of
these shows Danny we also have the one
and only Ben Simon on the st. Louis team
you may know Ben from the numerous live
streams and productions that he takes
part in we also have a st. Louis player
Doug Eckert on the team can't forget
Doug Eckert
when over some of his games or will
rather one of his games in my class dug
a very strong feed a master a u.s.
championship player in the past is on
our team we also have other famous
people Arjun Arjun
everybody knows Arjun everybody knows
Rachel the youngsters in st. Louis the
future of chess here in st. Louis that
are definitely making some waves as they
get a little older and a lot better at
chess
every year they seem to be improving we
also have eight son of youngsters from
our select chess program including Felix
Vinny Raja Alex shengshi Erin and I
think that's it from our select chess
program we also have Isabelle playing
for us we have miss Shaw chess club
employee Nash all playing for us we also
have let's see not Eric tkachenko Eric
dipped out on us if you could believe it
instead of Eric we have I had the
last-second replacement here as well oh
my gosh so much going on our last-second
replacement for Eric is of course Luke
Yee Lukey one of the strongest players
in the selection program going for that
national master title is Luke and he's
on our team here tonight we also have
standing in for Chess Club employee Nick
Crisco we have Jacob Sanders taking his
place Jacob a strong local youngster
himself also I believe does some twitch
streaming and that more or less rounds
out our team of 20 players I think I
mentioned everybody we've got them all
in here we've got them all so it's going
to be really tough for San Francisco to
take us all out we'll do a quick run
around all of the boards give them
everybody in that quick shout out as we
get going
we see Jacob here in the chat Alexi also
a guy from the st. Louis area who
teaches a lot of these youngsters chest
so he'll be cheering us on cheering on
I'm sure one or two of the students in
this match as we get ready to get
underway it looks like we have one
minute to the start time just one minute
until we get going until we get underway
for this big match for this big match
okay
and trying to keep track of all these
people it looks like our number one
player here is Aaron karinski also known
as sketchy moves number 2 J wills that
is justice Williams number 3 is Julian
and number 4 is Jonathan Rance
everybody knows Jonathan trans head of
the video Department and board for for
us in this matchup if you do care to
know about some of the opponents we're
facing off eric lee on board one who is
2369 USCF on board two for them is nuts
roasts who is Natalya Saudi Cova
something like that number three seems
to be
ruyan number four meanwhile is Josiah
Stearman so a lot of strong players on
the San Francisco and three two one zero
the match is officially started so why
don't we take a quick look at some of
these games if it'll let me pull it up
here so here we have ah I see a problem
in my streaming abilities so I've set
this up to only be for one board so
we'll look at just one board at a time
perhaps of course we have here on board
one Erin Griffin ski taking on Eric Lee
and this is our top board in the entire
match international master air Kavinsky
of course webster student taking on
webkinz here otherwise known as eric lee
on board two we have justice Williams
justice Williams taking on nut roast
board 3 we have Julian pearl a co board
for Jonathan's trance board 5 seems to
be chess playing wolf authorized known
as Danny Huachuca board 6 dishonor on
your cow is talia cervantes board 7 is
tau puri which I believe is the account
Arjun is playing on board 8 Luke Yi 2008
board 9 wolf team 2018 that has got to
be Jacob Sanders I
think I don't know for certain another
last-second no that is Rachel that is
Rachel Lee that is Rachel this just in
that is Rachel board 9 I believe I
haven't lost track is chess fans 2019
other Arizona's shengshi qianxi on board
19 board 20 that's got to be Erin Linn
that is Erin board Oh 11 I've lost track
we've got Vinnie we've got Doug Eckert
all the way down here with a 1588 rating
Doug wanted me to inform you all his
chest comm rapid rating is from his wife
playing on his account important that
this information goes out next up we
have in this shawl then we have Jacob
Sanders then we have chess world
scientist who is also known as a Rajah
and then we have moving hoaxes
who is oh my gosh this is so much Felix
we've got Felix there we've got cupcake
2 4 6 cupcake of course is Isabelle and
rounding out the team is the one and
only Ben Simon but why don't we stick
with just a couple games for the moment
let's take a look at Erin Griffin skis
position here against webkinz Erin of
course is our board one as I've been
saying and what's going on in this
position well it looks like he's got the
white pieces here and he's got a little
bit of advantage in space if I can just
back up through this game it looks like
it was a closest iliyan cycling through
here well not quite a closest William
and E for an f4 take some of these
central squares erin chooses to Fink
head of this dark square bishop he goes
for Bishop c4 and this is our current
position okay so the theme of this game
is going to be all about peace activity
the center is semi open which means
you're not going to see a ton of closed
center type of pawn storms that you
would normally see here both sides are
just going to look to get their pieces
active and get into the game this Bishop
on b2 is already a stellar piece for
Erin looking on this long diagonal right
now we do have some tension between
these bishops Erin chooses to play
Bishop b5 rather than take on e6 taking
on e6 does double black pawns but it
would open open up this rook on the F
file
as well as control a lot of key squares
here in the center so Bishop b5 instead
kind of side steps that look for Aaron
to develop this night out to f3 and make
a decision on what to do with this King
it's a little bit unclear yes so first
team to 20.5 wins is of course a two
round match so the players will play
once and then they'll rematch with the
opposite colors and black has just
broken with the move d5 so this is a
really critical moment here for Aaron
Black is trying to break free with d5
trying to open up the center trying to
get all of his pieces into the game so
how in response to this is going to
dictate the rest of the game he could
play a move like e5 which locks down the
center a little bit but then black is
going to be able to play moves like 94
taking control of this central square
and I'm not sure it's my favorite for
white although I don't see what else you
can really do he's a little bit stuck
because these pieces on the Kings side
aren't really in the game just yet and
this King is still stuck in the center
so he does take on d5 now I was just
expecting a simple Knight takes d5 from
black and from there I was thinking
black might be able to make use of this
diagonal in some way to get at this King
a little bit of risky play from Aaron
here I'm not sure if this is my favorite
position I've ever seen him get yeah and
actually there's there's this move
Bishop f5 that you might have to look
out for as well looking at the C to pawn
so I'm not convinced Aaron Aaron is
doing well we'll jump back to this game
momentarily but let's instead jump over
to justice Williams on board to justice
of course has the black pieces here if I
can flip the board he's playing against
new trost who according to my sheet is
Natalya Saudi Cova who is a 2181 USCF
player and he's got black here but
what's going on it looks like his
position does not have too many problems
at all this is the type of opening where
black plays somewhat conservatively by
not going for too much directly in the
center just playing solidly not making
any weaknesses the downside for black
here is this Bishop slightly stuck on
this d7 square but if black can find a
way to activate this Bishop I think
black has absolutely no problems at all
there's just an exchange on e5 and what
this means is that I think black has
already found his path to improving this
bishop expect to see moves like Bishop
c6 to follow with the idea of going for
this d4 break this is how black can
activate the pieces so of course we see
Bishop III now from white this is aimed
at making d4 a little bit harder to play
so both players know it's all about the
d4 square if black can play d4 black
frees all of his pieces and will be
doing quite quite well if white can
prevent d4 well there's going to be this
nagging problem of this bishop on c6
that you're going to have to look out
for with the black pieces how do you
activate this Bishop it's not super
clear and that's what justice is
thinking about right now so if I'm in
his shoes I'm finding any way I can to
get this bishop into the game right now
there's this threat to our bishop in the
way so what can we do about it let's
pause and think for a moment the move
Queen b6 does come to mind with the idea
of snapping off this bishop on e3 and
putting some pressure on b6 if you play
move like b6 this was kind of the most
natural move that I could think of but
then you might get met with the move
Bishop d4 and what white does with this
move is really solidly plans this Bishop
on the square where you want to move
your pawn and it's going to be extremely
difficult to get the move d4 in if
that's how this game develops in the
meantime I guess I I do like this move
Queen b6 I also like an idea a simple
rook c8 just gets this rook into the
game you could consider castling here
with black but I might want to hold off
another turn or two before I end up
doing that
in the meantime moves like a6 and b5 can
also be considered but he does go for my
main choice which is Queen b6 like I
said it's all about this d4 square and
so justice is looking to just directly
take control of it here and I'm
interested to see how Natalya actually
wants to respond to this
yes so we do see a trade and now I
wouldn't be surprised if we actually saw
Queen III directly stopping d4 but now
92 is actually a pretty clever way to do
it I missed this idea now Knight b3 is
the idea in response to d4 so we still
cannot play it just yet that's pretty
clever by Natalia so instead we see
knight c6 once again I'm not lying to
you guys it's a battle for the d4 square
here so justice brings in the night ok
let's see what Natalia is going to do
about that move Knight B 3 doesn't
strike me as correct here B 3 isn't
really a great square for the knight
what I could consider clean III but with
the Queen's off the board White's
pressure actually lessens quite a bit if
white can't get up the King somehow then
white is is simply kind of playing for
nothing so the Queen III it probably
won't be played Knight f3 might come on
the board but then the danger is king
black just play d4 immediately and I
think he can which is why Talia is
probably taking some time here I quite
like justices position I'm not sure what
white can do to prevent this idea of d4
and as such I think he's going to be
doing quite well why don't we check back
in on a different game so yeah we do see
rook d1 before I step away I just want
to see if I'm correct I want to see if
justice goes for this idea of d4 I think
he can play it now there is some
awkwardness with this rook being here
the line would probably go d4 Knight B 3
Queen b6 takes on d4 takes on d4 takes
on d4 takes on d4 and then maybe this
Bishop b5 move is actually going to be a
problem here so it looks like d4 can't
be played just yet that's pretty clever
once again by Natalia she's coming up
with these clever ways to make d4
unplayable it's all about this move so
if you didn't see and the tactic I'm
talking about ends with the move Bishop
b5 which hits the Queen and indirectly
hits this Bishop on d7 so d4 not yet but
not yet playable for black that's why we
see the move Queen b6 stepping out of
this Knight b3 tactic but now expect to
see Knight f3 from white simply getting
this Knight into the game guarding this
d4 square
so it's all hanging in the balance on
this square so yet for those of you
wondering Red Door siz unfortunately due
to some concerns over the closeness of
everybody in the studio we are just
having one commentator for the night so
you're stuck with me
so yeah night of three does come on the
board and it's really a question of how
can we get this d4 move in and I'm not
yet seeing it maybe it's going to be a
tough one for justice as well why don't
we check out Julian Pearl echoes game
now stepping over here we have Julian
against ji j 2018 which is really on for
the San Francisco mechanics Rui is a 22
42 u.s.c F player Julian of course a
strong national master in Hero of the
st. Louis Archbishop's to give us the
world championship in 2018 so let's see
what's going on here it looks like
Julian got here from a rosin in the
opening like this
Queen a4 check is the line chosen and
the simple Bishop d2 like it's all the
pieces out black breaks in the center
with e5 and this is the position on the
board so the question now for white is
can white get some more active pieces by
breaking in the center with E 5 black is
hoping to solve all of the opening
problems here by getting this Bishop
active both bishops on long open
diagonals giving this knight squares as
well and taking away White's advanced
central pawn on d4 so this is a critical
critical move for Julian which is why
you see him pausing and taking so much
time here going into a little bit of a
thing while he decides what to do about
this pawn on e5 there's a few options I
can see for white there's a tempting
move in the move of Queen b3 to put
pressure on f7 but I think a simple move
like Queen f6 would keep things under
control he goes for this move h4 Wow
so this is a highly tactical move Julian
is looking to kill his opponent
so if you do anything crazy like taking
on d4 probably you're gonna get met with
sacrifices or the simple Knight g5
immediately with threats on both f7 and
hh7 now g5 is play it but does that stop
Knight g5 or will Julian play it anyways
I think unfortunately it does
successfully stop Knight g5 if you go
for this type of sacrifice
well Black's gonna simply capture why it
will capture back and then efore locks
down this diagonal crushes your hopes
and dreams of playing Queen h7 there is
now move to consider though in the move
Queen g6 going for threats on f7 Bishop
e6 would probably be played in response
so I don't think this one quite does it
either so what can Julian do here it's
tough
yeah Bensimon actually in the match here
we'll take a look at his game as well
but looking at this I think black might
just be equalizing you what you don't
want to do here with white is try too
hard
to immediately win the game that's a
great way to find yourself over pressing
and find yourself in a lot of trouble so
if I'm Julian I'm now considering the
simple takes on e5 takes on e5 and
Bishop c3 you open up the center you get
your pieces on active squares and you
don't go for too much you just go for
nice activity a nice position and go
from there you just play chess you don't
need to go for crazy sacrifices to end
the game by any means at all you just
have to play good old-fashioned solid
chess so I like Julian's position but I
do want to mention I'm slightly
concerned that he might go for a little
bit too much here you don't want to over
press all right let's check back in on
our board one aaron Kavinsky
see what's going on here it looks like
Aaron's position has blown up in the
center as well so we last left off with
this move d5 Aaron captured back on d5 I
was mentioning I wasn't quite convinced
Aaron's position was so great these
pieces on the Kings side were
undeveloped and I was a little bit
worried that black could take advantage
of this somehow
making use of this diagonal the game
continued with Bishop f5 eyeing the c2
Pont Aaron solved this with the move
rook c1 but it does feel a little bit
shaky now Queen b6 comes on the board
and this is not a move I would have
expected and I slightly suspect this
move is just incorrect it's a little bit
unnatural putting this Queen on b6 it's
preparing to bring a rook perhaps to the
D file but it doesn't do much you know
what I mean it just doesn't do much and
now if White's lucky he'll hold on to
this pawn for a little bit and manage to
be a little bit annoying perhaps
actually now I'm seeing black was going
for some threats on C 2 followed by an
ice queen III but Knight f3 was errant
simpler response and now after rook d8
and queen f2 we see a trade of Queens
the c2 pod falls off the board but after
Bishop c4 and rook e1 I believe here
Aran has pretty much consolidated into a
perfectly fine position you see after
the Queen's get treated off the White
King has a lot less to worry about the
white pieces have successfully been
brought into the game and it's actually
gonna be black with some weaknesses to
take to take a look at here this d5 pawn
doesn't yet seem to be falling off the
board although it does fall off the
board
but now white is going to get this e 7th
pawn in exchange and that's exactly what
we see happen Bishop takes h3 happens
but now as we catch up to the light
position rook takes b7 and Aran is now
doing totally totally fine I was a
little bit worried about his position
there for a while when he was so
underdeveloped but now he has this nice
active rook on b7 his opponent has the
bishop pair but not a great way to make
use of it just yet and I think Aaron
will be doing all right in this endgame
I will mention I do still slightly
prefer the black pieces just due to this
nice bishop pair and the openness around
the white king but I think white is
doing ok you might expect to see a
little rear out of this Bishop actually
back to to a square like III this is the
diagonal that Aaron needs to keep
control of otherwise
is this Bishop might actually start to
cause some problems for this King
so Bishop g4 is probably aimed at
preventing that idea by putting pressure
on this night now what can Aaron do
about this hmm maybe he's in a little
bit more trouble than I was giving him
credit for the movie rook d3 might also
be under consideration if I'm Aaron I'm
probably playing the move rook c2 here
once again with the idea of rerouting
this bishop you need to get this Bishop
into the game and you need to give this
Knight a little bit of mobility
why not wreckage one instead of rook
takes b7 that's a good question
well if Rick h1 what would happen you're
attacking this bishop and behind it
you're attacking this bishop I imagine
the move rook age 5 is playable but I'm
trying to find if black has anything
better okay
perhaps black does have something better
upon second glance if you play the move
rag h1 I think you're gonna get met with
Bishop f8 when you can still take this
pawn but now this Bishop will simply
move up to g4 as we saw in the game and
there's no real problems for black and
your rug doesn't actually belong on this
h-file okay Bishop g4 is played in the
game
rook BC 7 says Sai Krishna but I don't
fully understand the point of this move
I like rook c2 you really need to
reroute this Bishop to this diagonal
that's the critical diagonal for white
here if you keep control this diagonal
you keep your Kings safe and you keep
yourself in the game ok he goes for Ric
CC 7 though this is a little bit more
active this is playing to win
as we say he's going after f7 and giving
black concrete problems so my way of
playing was perhaps a little bit more
passive Aaron is throwing caution to the
wind and just going after this black
King saya Karsh says always play Bishop
f8 Ben Simon scores first blood oh boy
Ben Simon seems to have won his game on
the 20th board against stars' Erica
bringing the st. Louis
team to a roaring start he destroyed his
opponent up apiece
in this end game taking off these ponds
and with this we go into an early lead
also note that someone else has already
won for Saint Louis that is wolf team
2018 who is the one and only Rachel Lee
Rachel of course
the adorable killer chess player on the
st. Louis Archbishop's I guess she's
getting less adorable as she gets older
she used to be a adorable little kid who
would just be at the chess club having a
fun time but now she just beats
everybody at chess and it's no fun okay
but she seems to have won her game as
well against an international master Wow
against EC Winslow let me see who this
is on the San Francisco team you see
Winslow I'm looking for him here it
looks like Elliott Winslow is this true
is he an international master my
goodness 22:78 USCF rating seems to be
an IM goes down to Rachel one of the top
players in her age group I don't
remember exactly how old she is anymore
but I remember she was always right at
the top of the list for her age group
definitely someone you're gonna want to
keep an eye on as she gets older and
this game just seemed to go her way she
goes after the King Knight age six
Bishop takes six and Wow
this is just a devastating attack this
Bishop not capture ball due to tactics
wait a second I don't understand chess
this games too complicated for me why
didn't black take this bishop I don't
understand I'm thinking about it I'm
thinking about it
hold on hold on let me ask my good
friend that the chess engine Queen f7 is
the move and if Bishop
oh you can't move this Bishop okay Queen
f7 just destroys black here obviously
Rachel saw it everybody saw it besides
perhaps Erik wins list so that's like
your cafe and now after rook g7 and rook
takes c7 this game is just dead
incredible play from Rachel so we are up
to 2-0 as you can probably see on your
screen there show us the whole game
alright I'll go through this one just
for you guys it started a four-seat but
it was the Sicilian niger a6 Bishop g5 e
six line and now F for Queen f3 I don't
know all the theory here but Rachel
takes off this knife pushes g5 and goes
for the throat as you should do in the
knight or F and while b4 was responded
to with this move F takes G six this is
crazy stuff I'm not sure if this is
totally theory or not but Wow impressive
stuff from Rachel so black takes a
knight white takes a knight and now the
classic case of using your opponent's
pawns against them Rachel hides behind
this pawn on b2 and is looking to kill
the black King in the meantime Knight f5
always a great move and Knight h6
is really I think the the winning move
here who Rachel getting the attack
through breaking through on the Kings
side
meanwhile blacks attack on the Queen
side just seems meaningless yet we see
the rerouting and energy 7 f5 was
probably just a blunder but even if
black doesn't play f5 here if you play
some normal move like Queen e5 rook
takes f7 is coming on the board and
you're you're kind of just getting
destroyed here kind of just getting
destroyed ok let's jump back to board to
see how justice Williams is doing here
justice on board to has this position
and it's gonna take my brain just a
second here to catch up with what's
going on in the meantime oh my gosh in
the meantime we've won two more games
we've won two more games Wow
alright first of all let me say
something reasonable about this position
I'm gonna count the pawns seems to be 6
to 7 justice is in fact down upon here
but with some pressure against this
black King I'm gonna be honest with you
here I think I prefer blacks position
black is just up upon and seems to be
doing all rights I think the moves like
be 5 and d4 are gonna be in the future
probably black doesn't want to rush
these things though and just play simple
improving the moves even g5 can come
the board when this rook is safe on f6
and guards all of blacks weaknesses so I
black is doing pretty well here
I think justice in a little bit of
trouble rook g3 I imagine just g5 from
black is going to be enough the simple
g5 is going to be enough here and it's
looking tough that the Queen isn't
actually a little bit trapped on g4 okay
looking tough for justice but let's not
dwell on that Jonathan has won his game
against the one and only
Josiah Stearman let's take a look at
this one see how this came about
it looks like the material here it looks
like this was some kind of French French
appeal Jonathan took some space with d4
in the opening let's just look from here
rook b8 b5 Jonathan expands on the Queen
side meanwhile Josiah expands on the
Kings side we see Bishop b7 Bishop f4
hits the rook so the rook moves and now
this is pretty instructive from Jonathan
you move the pieces away from the Kings
side so you don't want your opponent to
actually expand with tempo you want to
get them kind of out of the way so these
pawn pushes aren't coming with threats
to your pieces now v5 from Josiah might
be a little bit too ambitious here
taking all the central space but giving
up this d5 square which Jonathan uses to
great effect here the bishop drops back
to d2 but now c4 and it seems to be
Jonathan whose pawn breaks are a little
bit more relevant here Queen f2 we take
on d3 now after night before the white
queen side seems to be collapsing Josiah
tried breaking out with at six
but Jonathan simply takes this free pawn
queen h4 is putting on some pressure but
now Knight takes e5 and the white
position seems to be crumbling and now
it's pretty much checkmate or bust for
white and it looks like white ended up
with bust rook f6 is a clever move
tempting black to take this piece but of
course Jonathan ignores it plays the
move Knight 95 instead and now it's just
that
we see a trade and another trade Queen
takes is a little bit strange I'm not
sure why White was so happy to trade
Queens here because now after another
trade this is simply busted and Jonathan
easily wins this game the score is now
four to one it looks like the mechanics
seem to have won on some other board in
the meantime who else one who else won
for us oh no Nichelle lost his game
Michelle lost his game we won't worry
about it moving hoax has also won moving
Haute's is of course Felix from our
select chess program winning his game
but let's stick with a game here jumping
back to Andrew Ben ski on board one
what's going on here oh no bad things
are going on here what happens
what so yeah this is just some some
tactics going wrong I think some tactics
gone wrong so in this position I was
pausing and I was talking a lot about
the move rook c2 I thought Aaron should
play rook C to get this Bishop to e3 and
get his kings safe and I am gonna have
to stand by that assessment because what
happened in the game after rook c7
rookie 395 well this rook comes into t2
and after this nice move by a black rook
d8 things seem to be crumbling apart at
the seat at the seams just falling apart
at the seams if you take this bishop
here sorry I guess I can't quite make
the moves on the board if you take the
bishop on g4 I think you're gonna get
met with some checkmating threats I
haven't quite worked out the exact
checkmate yet but I imagine it starts
with the check kingi for another check
king e5 and from there it's it's got
ously tough for me to calculate but
what's going on
so Knight takes g4 gosh I don't even
know perhaps even you could just play a
simple takes on g4 and then okay wait
okay I dunno rookie - after king e5 and
then rook d6 is
is the simple checkmate finally got
there in the end so if you take this
Bishop on g4 just to give you the full
line you get met with rook 8 to d3 King
e4 f5 check King e5 rookie to check King
f6 rook d6 with checkmate
so that Bishop is untouchable after this
nice move by webkinz and this is just
def for Aaron now imagine instead if
Aaron had played the move rook to c2
if rook c2 had come on the board then
there's none of this garbage on the
second rank you can play 95 with a good
conscience and play this Bishop out to
e3 and just stick with a solid position
sometimes that's what you need to do and
I think that's what needed to be play
played here rather than this craziness
that Aaron went for unfortunate and now
I think he's simply in a losing game and
it's going to be tough for in here but
maybe he can try to hold on to this one
he's looking to get rid of the remainder
of blacks pawns and if he succeeds in
that well it's nothing more and then a
draw with rook and Knight against two
rooks
so yeah dorsa has also found the line
that I found Wow
Rick takes f4 is not what I expected I
expected black to try to hold on to this
Potter or at least hold on to this pawn
pawn Oh a little more pressure here
Aaron now is looking to solve all of
those problems by by taking off this
remaining pawn with knight c6 is this
just a draw now I think this is just a
draw this just looks like a draw to me
the black king is kind of pinned in on
the first rank and I think Aaron is is
somehow saving this game well done to
Aaron if a move like King f8 I think
probably just simply Knight back to g6
is going to come and if you try to break
free with stuff like King eh well let's
see maybe you get met with 95 so I'm
expecting Knight 96 check King 8 and
then back to 95 and there's just gonna
be too many threats on this King for
black to be able to hold on to the a
pond so if the a pawn Falls just a draw
an endgame
I think black really let something slip
here black really let something slip and
note of course the King cannot step off
of the eighth-ranked here otherwise
knight c6 comes with check and Aaron
simply picks up this pawn or does he now
I'm confusing myself let's see if okay
so a knight c6 check the King would have
to move again and then the accurate move
King's c5 would have to come on the
board and then this pawn is simply
falling no way to defend it since the
King f8 and Aaron's taking his time here
but I really think that this is just
going to be going to be a dead draw well
done to Aaron holding on in that tough
position in the meantime we seem to have
won one more game let's keep an eye on
it it looks like have we won one more
game I'm not totally sure
oh well wolf team has actually won his
sec or her second game this is Rachel I
keep forgetting Rachel won her second
came against the International Master
Wow you hate to see it for the San
Francisco mechanics Rachel leads just
taking out the International master
every opportunity looks like this game
was a qgd exchanged Rachel simply gets
their pieces into the game breaks with
c5 doesn't flinch at all this garbage
that white is trying to do with h3 and
g4 White Queen side castles but now the
simple takes on d4 takes on d4 and 94
this is a killer Knight shoving its way
into the position blocking out all of
these white pieces and there's not much
that white can do about it King b1 was
played in the game but now rook c8 is
killer on this open file against the
Queen and white is really getting
punished for his impunity here queenside
castling and just pushing on the Kings
side but Rachel playing him very
accurately and Wow the nice move III
hits the rook on h1 and advances the
pawn opening up this bishop getting it
into the game rook hg 1 is met with
takes on f2 Queen takes f2 and now
Knight takes e5 this is crazy let's get
Rachel Lee on the archbishop's why isn't
Rachel Lee on
Bishop's turn off the engine okay
Queenie eight and my goodness this is
just this is crazy stuff from Rachel
Bishop c5 and she just picks up this
pawn in chess is just easy huh chess is
just easy when you're a prodigy I guess
chess is just easy yeah rook takes c3
Queen c5 resigns chess is easy why are
you even trying of course you can't take
this rook do two queen takes c3 when
this rook falls on a one and Rachel just
destroying this international master
like it's like it's nothing
Rachel for the archbishop's 2021 you
heard it here first
okay so Rachel just totally dominating
her opponent jumping back to Aaron's
endgame I want to check this out see
what he's doing here I think things are
still going well for him probably this
night belongs back on this 'if I've
Square and I think things are gonna be
okay things are gonna be okay
it looks scary out there Aaron but
things are gonna be okay it's gonna work
out for you I feel good I feel good like
I said you just need to get this Knight
into the game and put some pressure on
both this King and this pawn he's taking
his time here but I really think 95 is
is the way to go I'm not sure what else
you can really even play here okay 97 I
mean it's it's the same idea you just
need to get this Knight to c6
what's her rating every time I check her
rating it's gone up another hundred
points last I saw she was like 2150 or
something I'm sure she's 2400 by now
don't ask me Doris is laughing out there
maybe she knows but for a while there I
would like look up her rating every
month just for fun and I would go up a
hundred points she's ridiculous it's
stupid
okay so again knight c6 this is an
interesting endgame Aaron really holding
on here he has to make threats against
this King otherwise it's just dead lost
if he can take off this pawn it is a
draw but that is a big if so good luck
to Aaron in the meantime of course we
managed to win another game the score is
now seven to one we won two games oh my
goodness
crazy Vinnie Vinnie won his game go
Vinnie Vinnie another member of the
Select chess program
has won his game for us let's check out
how Doug Eckert is doing we have not
checked in on Doug yet today I went over
one of his games from my class one of
the st. Louis legends as I have deemed
their name to be and it looks like he
has a pretty nice position against his
opponent here let me look up who his
opponent is who is sterling sterling
looks like Isaac sterling who is not the
strongest player USCF but putting up a
good fight here against Doug
unfortunately for Isaac sterling it
looks like this d6 square is under quite
a bit of pressure so Queen e7 goes after
the g5 pawn but is it enough it was
actually a really interesting position
here I like what Doug has done he's
taken control of the D file and in
particular this d6 square but it's just
a question now of if he can turn it into
something concrete
right now there's tactical variations
including Bishop takes e5 available to
them which definitely deserve some
thought I'm not sure exactly how it's
all going to work out here even Knight
takes e5 could be considered with this
rook d7 idea to follow but I think I
really like Doug's position I think this
should this should go well for him 20
players per team 20 players per team and
we've already won seven games it's first
to 20 and a half to win the match and
right now of course as you can hopefully
see on your screen it is a solid 7 to 1
solid 7 to 1
rook b5 check okay so someone seems to
found a win and Erin convinced Keys game
why don't we take a look here in the
meantime it looks as though justice
Williams has actually won his game
that's not what I was expecting someone
says rook b5 check in the night is
falling
ah you caught me so yeah if 95 then rook
b5 check would be hitting this night end
of King d6 there is this annoying move
of rook to d4 check to kind of put you
out of the game so well done finding
that tactic that I missed
although wait a second does it even lose
the game I'm not sure because King e6
then if rookie for there's this move
again and I'm threatening checkmate I'm
not sure not if I've lost the knight but
I did not see rook b5 check so 97 is
still coming with threats to the king
but yeah 95 rook b5 check King d4 King
d6 Rick d4 King e6 rookie for King d6
I'm not sure if the Knights falling
there but Aaron does go for this instead
the game continued King 896 as expected
and now after rook a1 aaron is trying to
find a way to take off this pawn you
obviously can't do it immediately
because rook b5 check comes through in
the end
but can you play this nice move King e6
now and get a draw with threats to the
king that is the question here I really
like this move King e6 and I think it's
it's definitely what era needs to go for
so he goes for it I imagine the only
winning try now is to give this check in
force 95 but if you don't simply rook
takes a5 is going to come on the board
so we see rook e1 now 95 might be good
and so yeah King d6 is dead okay this is
as simpler keeping up pressure here but
yeah no no wait a second no it's not
simpler now a4 what's going on
nobody knows okay King f8 must be played
I don't see anything else
so King f8 and now what is happening I
don't like this move can be 6 why was
king b6 played you had to play 95 here I
think you had a point
five now 97 check okay so the king is
still pinned to the back rank and this
is the draw he found it he found the
draw he did it
king d6 found the draw Aaron saw more
than I did if the king dare step to the
seventh ranked Knight c5 check comes on
the board and the a upon Falls the King
steps to get well there's Knight f6
check can't go this way due to checkmate
the King steps back to f8 when 97
repeats same deal if you go to g8 Knight
f6 check can't go to h8 cuz Rick h7 is a
checkmate so back to f8 for you and then
Knight back to d7 excellently done from
Aaron here so the best black can do now
is play move like King g7 go for a
knight c5 King f6
na and then Rick takes a four and try to
win this rook versus night and game but
he really should not be able to do it
against the strong Aaron Kavinsky in the
meantime though as I mentioned justice
Williams actually managed to win his
first game here I very much didn't like
his position that we saw earlier on here
yeah in this position I thought g5 and
black really had no problems
h4 was justices tried to cause some
complications but what's this was was
Rick f4 not Eureka for wasn't played due
to e6 hanging interesting I might have
considered the move rook f4 here anyways
giving up East 6 instead simply rook
heceta f8 puts pressure on f2 but now g5
false if you wanted to play rook f8 why
not include the move takes on age 4 that
would have been much better just
preserving this age pawn no need to give
up the pawn like this so I think this
move rook f8 is really where black went
wrong here now white is getting active
and coming coming out black with a force
so you ever cage 3 there's open files
now and this King is going to end up a
little bit weak g4 and ricochet
tactically defense this pawn due to some
threats Queen D for those centralizes
rook over to the H file and while f4 I
might have one I still like black and
takes
what's happening how did white win this
game
III was them what is III what is
happening threatening checkmate oh my
gosh this is this is chess it's the most
obscene Oh justice had black everything
makes sense everything makes sense
black won the game here with this move
III okay the whole entire time I was
commentating this game I thought justice
was white and I thought he was getting
killed but justice with the black pieces
winning this game so I'm not totally
crazy well I did have a very very good
position here with the move g5 and he
did manage to convert it so good job
justice I was just wrong about which
side justice had okay funny stuff but we
got there in the end
good job of Justice William converting
in that game it looks like San Francisco
has scored their second point of the
match
it looks like Erin Lin has actually
fallen to his opponent
Alaa Han Alejandro Canalis who is a 1700
unfortunate for Aaron we also have a
draw now and oh my gosh draws everywhere
Aaron did get the draw in his game
Julian pearl Aiko has also drawn his
game in on this board we were talking
about this game from this position here
when I was saying
Julian shouldn't go crazy he should just
play normal moves like this and in fact
that's what he did but it just didn't
turn out to be enough in this case he
got his pieces active but some pieces
come off the board he wins a pawn but
wasn't able to win the game some crazy
stuff is happening now and we see this
trade come on the board and going after
the king but in the end as we all know
all rook end games are drawn so it's
that's real tough all on games are drawn
it isn't Justin yeah justice had black I
got everything wrong it's all my fault
I'm sorry okay
so good draw from Julian other results
chess-playing wool from Danny Machuca
has actually drawn his game against
Chiron Griffith who is of course a very
strong player Chiron is 2470 USCF Danny
only in 1900 managed to draw good for
Danny drawing with the white pieces here
any tough-looking in game all right
let's see how this one it was a trump
hausky and it was 69 especially Danny
looks to have gotten the central
advantage and simplified a little bit
and just played good solid chess
taking on d4 blockading this pawn
expanding in the center getting active
once again some trouble now around his
king but he managed to navigate the
problems trading off getting his King in
taking off this so that's a big draw for
the Archbishop's that was one of the
heavily favored matchups for them and oh
my gosh all the games are ending now
twelve and a half to five and a half in
our favor now thirteen and a half so I
believe that means almost all of the
games are over from round one let's
check in on Lukey who was in severe time
pressure against Nathan Nathan 3:14
what's going on here looks like an end
game F sevens attacked Lukey plays f6 oh
gosh he's pinned Queen d5 comes on the
board now f5 has to be played at five
very tricky move now okay so we do see
takes and a drawn end game it looks like
the black King is doing okay now that
the rook is off the board what's this
there's a couple checks to look out for
King g2 is forced and now Queen of three
can come king h2 and what's going on
here yeah the simple Queen f4 we might
see a repetition from Luke I would
expect to see though King h6 and King g5
to play for the wind okay he's going in
for this end game now and now this
should just be a dead draw from what I
can tell King g7 has to be played Luke
okay he goes and white is
a little bit faster actually but black
has the opposition he needs to play Oh
No
is Luke EU Oh Luke's losing oh no oh no
this tension with these pawns on the G
file it turns out to be devastating here
and Lucas has just dead lost unfortunate
turn in this this Queen in this King and
pawn endgame that's why you never go
into a King and pawn endgame without
calculating everybody never go into a
King and pawn endgame without
calculating so that one goes to the San
Francisco mechanics now I think all the
games from the first round are done in
that first round of play it looks as
though let's see the score was six and a
half to twelve and a half if I'm doing
the math correctly how many games are
there one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
there's only 19 so let's see 1 2 3 I
think there's only 19 games rather than
20 so I think the final score there was
six and a half to 12 and a half in our
favor in the first round of play now two
games in the second round or all already
finish nichelle unfortunately lost both
of his games to his opponent and Rachel
Lee of course defeating the
international master going to no wins
her second game as well now in this
second round let's check back in with
somebody we haven't seen yet somebody we
haven't seen yet let's check back in
with the one and only Ben Simon we saw
that he won his first round how is he
faring in the second round with the
black pieces
it looks like reasonably well then up up
just one pawn here some danger to his
king but he seems to have it under
control for the moment I expect king b6
for black is going to be the move he
doesn't applying it there's no real
constructive checks if you play Queen d8
simply King a6 and then you have nothing
more than one more check maybe there's a
few more checks actually something Ben
could consider is going a little bit
wild and running up the board but king
a6 is the move I expected now Queen d6
with rookie six I imagine but then
there's queen a3 check and maybe somehow
white is hoping for a perpetual in this
position with the black king struggling
to find shelter Queen a3 maybe king b5
is the way to go so against king b7
queenie 7 is a simple repetition but I
think king b5 to c6 might be the way to
go he chooses king c6 in this position
which is slightly different
I'm not sure I like the way Ben's
handling this it might end up just being
a simple draw by repetition here for Ben
is there chance that the Chess Club
might hold some Raptor blitz online
tournaments in the near future for club
members actually I would expect to see
that Alexi definitely that's been in the
works I think we're looking to do that
type of stuff more on Lee chess if
you're familiar we have the st. Louis
chess club quote-unquote team we've been
kind of test running some staff
tournaments and they've been going
really well so hopefully we end up
opening one up to to just Club members
but yeah definitely it's stuff like that
in the works Ben still trying to evade
these checks here we'll leave him to it
in the meantime
who do we want to look at who do we want
to look at no Doug did did end up
winning his game that we liked his
position in let's check out Arjun who
won his first game as well
Arjun is the other youngster that I'm
terrified of Arjun and Rachel Lee are
both incredible chess players that are
gonna go far in this world
I really think so those are two to look
out for he crushed his opponent in round
one I imagine we don't even have to look
and now in this round two he seems to
have a really good position from what
looks like maybe a sloth type of no it
was a Carol from a Carol let's see how
he got here looks like an exchange karo
he chooses a pretty conservative line
rate just defends his deep on and
develops his pieces he brings this night
around to III this is a nice move g3
just to stunt these pieces and now he
takes off black slaves great bishop so
with his unopposed bishop he's looking
to make inroads on the light squares
black plane very naturally
expanding with v4 and once again I got
everything wrong argent has the black
pieces okay so are just expanding very
naturally with b4 I like his position he
goes ahead and takes now Bishop b4 takes
off a key defender and what's going on
here
well this pawn looks like it's hanging
this pawn does look like it's hanging if
I'm Arjun I am taking this pawn for free
saying thank you very much I will take
your a pawn next and win this game so
great job by origin here I think
Argent's just simply winning upon with a
very nice position and he should be
winning this game I expect nothing less
from the up-and-comers here in st. Louis
I expect nothing less will leave Arjun
with his great position why don't we
check back in on Jonathan who managed to
upset his opponent feed a master Josiah
Steerman in the first round here it
looks like Jonathan once again in a
perfectly fine position it should not be
anything more than a draw for white but
it should definitely be in trouble don't
think there's any way for white to
escape these checks but up a pawn you
can't really ask for too much more here
Jonathan should be getting a drop one
and a half out of two against Josiah
well done
to Jonathan well done to Jonathan to be
sure
although uh-oh looks like San Francisco
managed to win another game somewhere
along the line what happened it looks
like Aaron unfortunately fell once again
in the second round to his opponent we
won't look at that game we only look at
the wins
you knew right from the start that I'll
get all the names right well I'm doing
my best over here there's a lot going on
20 games is a lot to try to follow okay
so good stuff from Jonathan things seem
to be going well
every board I click on so I'm hoping
this match ends up in our favor hoping
this match ends up in our favor all
right let's check back in on the key
board one game of Aaron gurbin ski it
looks like Aaron is completely winning
in this position his King is perfectly
safe in this nice structure with f2g 3
and H for this Queen can guard the f2
pond from afar and he's connected
passers on the Queen side are going to
be the story of the game this is just
devastating by white and once again I've
got the names wrong aaron has black
Aaron's getting crushed here he's gonna
lose this game now I've thought that
before but you know Aaron he's he's a
swindler if there ever was one
I'll say that about him he comes up with
chances that I would never think existed
and he'll have to do a miracle here to
stop these past pawns in the Queen side
if I'm Aaron I'm looking for ways to get
at this King now looking for any way I
can to shake loose this Queens
connection with this F pawn and trying
to just get at this King any way I can
that's the only way Aaron's gonna be
able to hold on to this game I don't see
a way for it to work out for him but
Aaron looking to swindle here in some
trouble alright let's check out justice
Williams position here hopefully I'm
looking at the right side here yes
finally I am justice with the white
pieces okay and what's going on here
this looks like a very complex type of
structure what opening did this come out
of came out of the English open and
opening well known for complicated
structures I imagine and once again I
think I have to say I like Justice's
position I think I like Justice's
position
Queen a6 and I think the winning plan
now for justice is it's gonna be to play
a four and a five that is going to break
down this structure on the Queen side
and create a passed pawn for justice and
with that passed upon he should be able
to win the game now if black is going to
have any chance at all
I think Natalya is her name she's going
to have to break open things on the
Kings side or in the center so she has
to do that immediately otherwise a four
and a five is just devastating this is
going to be how justice wins the game
now with this knight vacating justice
can also consider moves like rook c6 but
I don't see any reason not to continue
with plan a here a four a five perhaps
96 is blacks idea but I don't think it's
severe enough even if you play 96 I'll
continue with a five you can take my
pawn I'll trade take b6 and rook c6 and
it's just devastating it's just
devastating storm all right storm wants
my advice for improvement at the 900
level
my advice is pretty similar to Dora's I
always tell people try really hard try
really hard in all your chess games that
means giving it the utmost focus that
you absolutely can trying your best
calculating thinking about each and
every move and after your games going
back analyzing your good analyzing those
games looking for mistakes that's the
key to getting better at chess it's not
just grinding out a ton of games and a
ton of tactics half-heartedly it's
giving each and every game your best you
have to try really hard to get better at
chess so that's my advice for you in the
meantime just as taking his time here
but I really do expect a four and a five
to be the way to play perhaps he's
worried about this move e5 from black to
try to break things open but I just
don't trust it me five weakens this d5
pawn and while it does open up some
lines like I think Black has to do I I
don't think it's in a favorable manner I
think yes so a four and a five is is
coming it's coming and it's coming with
a vengeance
humming with a vengeance the n86 does
happen I expected just a 5 there Rick c6
is a slightly more conservative way to
play it interfering with the Queen's
contact on b5 just preparing this a5
move no reason not to I suppose but I
thought a 5 in the previous position was
also perfectly fine now black is really
struggling here to find some way to slow
this down perhaps my only reservation
about playing rooks c6 is the move rook
c8 if black could play this move then
black would be freeing her position
considerably but I think unfortunately
there's a tactic with rook takes d6 if
or exceed so Rick c6 accurate chest from
justice and this is just going to be the
end of the line nothing to be done for
Natalya here he's just going to crush it
we are the st. Louis chess club well the
st. Louis chess club the force
okay so a five by Justice and I think
this game is perfectly in his hands
rook b8 now that's not enough to stop me
from playing a five a five on the board
you cannot capture otherwise rook takes
d6 wins the game and this is dead lost
good stuff from justice hopping over now
- Julian pearl Eiko's game I do wanna
mention we're up to fifteen points now
and originally the match was supposed to
have twenty players I believe only
nineteen showed up for the match so the
magic number is nineteen and a half we
get to nineteen and a half points the
match is ours in this game Julian seems
to be doing very very very well there's
so much pressure against this white King
and I don't see any compensation that
white has in exchange for it
King each one or King age - I think has
to be played now and already julian has
tempting options such as rook takes g2
cashing in for this Queen I don't think
that's the best he can do though I think
he should hold out for a little bit more
than that and look for better King h2
has to be played there's really nothing
else to be done here and from there I'm
just trying to find some way for Julian
to keep the pressure he could just play
some normal-looking move but what
normal-looking move should that be
Julian I'm sure is looking for a
knockout blow here this is the type of
position where there's something
something has to give you know what I
mean this something has to give here
White has allowed black too much in this
position but I don't see it just yet
perhaps the way to go is doing something
with this C pawn I don't like leaving
this C pawn just out and about here and
from there I want to play Queen d8 in
Bishop h4 this is something that's going
to create some nasty threats around the
White King if I can achieve this and
then I think the game is kind of in
Julian's grasp but what to do about the
C pawn it's not so easy oh yes so aakash
the problem with Knight h4 is I think
you're just allowing white to get away
with capturing
g-iii here if white can get these two
rooks for the Queen I think White's very
happy about that very very happy about
that I do in a note white is technically
up upon here and that's likely the
compensation that White's hoping for but
I just don't think it's enough so Julian
chooses c4 and this is how you resolves
the tension with the sea pond and now
that this tension is resolved I expect
to find them playing moves like Queen d8
moves to get more pieces into the game
you can even consider forming the
classic Alekhine's gun with rook g6 and
Queen to g8 just putting the maximum
amount of pressure on this g2 pawn here
and then moves like Knight h4 can come
on the board with this your Academy a
little bit more support so c4 from
Julian is how he starts okay so Bishop
II one I think is just losing the game
that's a free night gotta move the
knight when the night is a packed I
don't understand I don't understand I
don't get it free night Julian's gonna
win the game next let's check back in on
Dani Machuca Dani had a huge upset in
round one against his opponent feed a
master Chiron Griffith who is over 2400
USCF very strong player Dani Machuca and
1,900 USCF player managed to draw and
round one and it looks like he is
holding on for dear life in this
position although both players are
material seems to be equal for the
moment White's King stuck in the center
in the meantime blacks King also stuck
not in the center but on the h8 square
stuck in the corner so white is going to
look to get at that King and get his own
King safe with this check Wow so King f2
this allows day me the opportunity to
not take on d4 takes back with a check
but now a simple Queen c7 move I expect
and then things like Queen c5 are going
to be what Dani Machuca is looking for
here in order to consolidate a little
bit I definitely prefer the white pieces
in this case
but I think Danny is is doing an
admirable job of holding on to this
position a very admirable job
great wolf wants me to help him
understand I don't sometimes people hang
pieces it's just the way of the world
so 94 is forcing Danny's hand here with
this bishop mmm this move seems like a
good chess move I hate to say it but
this one seems like a winner d6 is also
attacked maybe you can try rookie 6 to
hold on rookie 6 seems like it might be
holding for the moment but it just feels
so shaky it feels so shaky the knight
takes f6 is gonna come although actually
okay maybe Bishop g7 maybe Bishop g7
here for Dani is is gonna be the move
you can also consider taking on d4 and
meeting Queen takes d4 check with rook
and g7 it feels very very loose and that
pin is going to be very awkward and
difficult to break but I don't see the
knockout yet for white as long as I
don't see the knockout I'm gonna hold
out hope for Danny I think Danny still
has some chances here Bishop takes h4
wasn't made bishop picks h4 was
unfortunately illegal due to this pin
this is a strong pin
mmm-hmm strong pin by Chiron here so
Danny is taking his time here I think
the move Bishop g7 is more or less the
best he can do you can also consider
Queen d8 maybe but you lose this pawn
you just yeah you hate to lose that pawn
you really hate to see it and it's it's
not gonna be pretty
I think it's got to be Bishop g7 here
what else can be done you could go
perhaps a little bit crazy and try
sacrificing this exchange here but it's
it's not gonna be anywhere near enough
not gonna be anywhere enough anywhere
near enough okay so Danny taking his
time tough position there for him
hopping back to the scoreboard here
looks like we're up to 17 points we need
one and a half more points to win the
match one and a half more points to win
the entire match some other results that
have come onto the board wolfteam 2018
won both of his games jumping down looks
like Jacob Sanders has rejoined us he
has won both of his games why don't we
take a look at his second win here
against Daniel pair love this was a game
and Dutch stone wall Jacob plants this
knight on e4 this is the key square in
the stone wall and takes back with the F
pawn opening the F file for his pieces
and now he activates the pieces and just
wins a piece on the B file from there
the rest looked to be fairly smooth
sailing just crushing Daniel good job to
jacob bringing home two points for us
other notable results Bensimon did end
up drawing his second game well done the
been scoring one and a half chess world
scientists of course chess world
scientist is a raja local kid in the
select chess program managed to battle
back losing his first round but
defeating his opponent jrc chess player
in round two with a checkmate
nonetheless good job to Raja okay other
notable results other notable results
let's see Vinny still playing Benny
still moving hooks man
to draw in the second round bringing us
all the more closer to that win let's
check back in on Vinny Vinny's been
playing a while here he's down to 52
seconds severe time pressure for Danny
whose opponent has ten minutes left on
the clock looks like his opponent in
this case is reka star a who is 1500
USCF and what's going on in this
position Wow
okay Vinny has a bishop on g7 now if
that were a queen this game would have
ended but it's not so some work still to
be done by Vinny comes up with this move
e to D 1 he's baiting his opponent into
capturing on C 1 when Queen takes C 1 is
going to be devastating with this Queen
just invading on the dark squares so
this is kind of the name of the game
here for Vinny if he can get this Queen
to h6 the game is over
if you cannot oh my gosh all right his
opponent has taken I think this is a
terrible terrible move this just looks
like checkmate now this game is over
Vinny is going to win Vinny going to a
no for the st. Louis team I love it I
love it Queen h6 unstoppable Queen h8
unstoppable that game is over
well done to Vinny that brings us to 18
we need a half point to win the game we
need a half point this game but with
Julian Hannah caught my eye let's check
back in here this was one I really saw
going his way
he won this piece 1 2 3 simply
consolidated now he offers some trades
and looks to protect his King looks to
get active and this game is just going
to be dead lost for white checking back
in here what is going on in the current
position Julian snatched off an a pawn
he still has this pressure on the G file
but now his queen is over here on the
Queen side creating threats on both
sides of the board the piece that
doesn't make a good impression is
unfortunately this night on d7 so look
to expect Julian to improve this night
one way
another trying to find any way to get
this night into the game maybe Knight b6
here is worth considering threatening to
take on c4 so I would expect c5 but now
this Knight can actually come back to
see 8 up to e7 and up to c6 and that is
how you get your knight in the game and
for Julian choses Knight d7 instead I
actually don't like this move quite as
much d yeah before expect Queen b5 you
just want to cement this pawn on this
square but now like this night it's it's
tougher to get it to c6 so I don't
really like this movie I like tonight c8
a little bit better not that it matters
Julian's just up a piece here and of
course is easily winning this game
other than that maybe the move Queen c4
was also worth considering but yet just
expect him to get this night into c6 and
this game is is gonna be over rook H
we're a wreck a to just expect to see a
6 no blocking off any threats
if rook a 5 well that means Queen e2 and
you're getting yourself into a world of
hurt a entire world a planet of hurt if
the move rook g2 Knight age 4
devastating stuff so simply a 6 year
from from Julian is a game ender it's a
game ender
okay in the meantime we still haven't
hit that magical number just yet haven't
hit the magical number yet checking back
in on Vinnie I expect his game to be
over very very soon yeah black try g5
this Queen gets in anyways it still just
checked me checking back in on another
player oh it looks like Arjun actually
lost that game unfortunate expected
Arjun to pull that one out and we have
gotten 18 points now cupcake cupcake
cupcake one cupcake the the game the
match ender cupcake of course is
Isabelle playing for us
$13.99 rated USCF manages to take down
her opponent here and wow this looks to
event quite the game it looks like
Isabelle just set off some bombs in
front of this black King taking off
every bit of shelter leaving no pawns
remaining and from there managed to find
a nice checkmate using both the rooks
rook c1 rook c2 rook H - that's a rook
lift if I've ever seen one and that is
checkmate we've officially tied the
match another half point means we win
and Vinnie has Mayton - on his board
this match is over Vinnie has won that's
19 points we win the game
we win the match San Francisco go down
just like I knew they would punching
them down destroyed demoralized San
Francisco should have known better than
to challenge the st. Louis chess club
alright let's check back in because the
match isn't over yet
losing my voice here I'm shouting so
much justice still with a good position
in this game last we checked in he had
just broken through this a5 move and I
was just talking up how well he had
played breaking through on this Queen
side and now he is the one with the
extra passed pawn and that should be
enough to win the game we see him
pushing this pawn up the board and in
this position unless black is making
immediate threats
expect to see white push this beep on on
every turn here I don't see a threat so
I expect to see the move b6
come on the board what else to do and
there it is as I say it he plays it I'm
so embarrassed to be in San Francisco
right now you should be great wolf
although you're in our chat so what
we'll call you a saint Lewisohn
nonetheless st. Louis in uh you know not
not not in reality but in spirit in
spirit thank you to Suba thank you for
the congratulations all right efore yeah
Queen c7 now would take off the Queen's
b7 is just promoting multiple ways to
win this game if I'm justice I play the
move Queen c7 here just to eliminate any
chance I'm gonna tack on my king and
this pawn just promotes by force and
that is that that is that so he plays b7
this also totally winning there's
nothing for black to do to get at the
white king even with the Queen on the
board and this is just going to be any
promotion isn't great wolf Danny Machuca
no Danny Machuca is chess playing wolf
easily confused for great wall no great
wolf is great wolf Danny there's so many
wolves there's also like wolf team 2018
which is Rachel chess playing wolf is
Danny as yes II look like I know what
I'm talking about Dennis in the chat
Queen see 795 well then I take this and
I push this and then I went but this one
works as well
Queen f5 means Queen d7 okay and now we
just one square to go one square to go a
little buddy just gets one just go one
more square you can do it one more
square Queen c8 and promote promotion
should be good enough for me I don't see
the threat to the White King if I'm
percent honest queen c8 if black dares
to take on e to I think I simply promote
not recapturing then any check to my
king I have Bishop f3 in response and
this game is over
so queen c8 be a Queen's is the end of
the game justice taking his time just
being absolutely certain that there's
nothing here for black
if you push this the knight c6 I'm not
sure which line Manny is talking about
to be honest okay he's talking about
Queen c7 so Queen c7 95 I just take here
and then okay you're taking back with a
knight I push here and you're saying
knight c6 I go here Knight b8
I mean sure that it's it's a lost
endgame I can go Bishop b4 if nothing
else and I'm winning a full piece but
it's fine
yeah we've officially won the match
officially won the match I think there
were only 19 games rather than the 20
that we're supposed to be so we are well
over the 18.5 mark you heard me
celebrating earlier cupcake got us to 18
I'm not sure who got us the last half
point it doesn't really matter but in
the end that was game oh no if Vinnie
Vinnie did it for us I remember
Vinnie brought us to 19 Vinnie the match
winner go Vinny in the meantime we've
gotten one more point on Julian's board
we expected Julian to win of course he
was just up this full piece and then wow
the tactic that I mentioned earlier was
actually the game ender rook g29 h4 came
onto the board how did I see it coming
I don't know sometimes lucky in the
meantime justice a couple more moves
have been played he chose Bishop takes
g5 fair enough and now bishop at 4 ends
okay
black gets to Queen but black loses the
king so it's it's a bit of a trade-off
Oh equals Knight check and Talia found
the best move checking the white king
one more time before ending the game we
love a good under promotion spite check
okay so justice winning that game as
well
Aaron unfortunately did end up losing
his game as I expected I've been
avoiding that game because it looked
terrifying let's check back in on Danny
Danny's game here against Chiron
Griffith Griffith so I was expecting
Danny to be in a little bit of trouble
here what did he end up doing oh no he
played rookie six oh you can't let this
night take this Bishop on f6 you need
that Bishop regard the dark squares this
has to be dead lost now nothing to be
done yeah
Danny's gonna lose this one if you guys
ever find yourself in this type of
position just know if your king is stuck
in the corner like this you need this
bishop here and if this bishop is dying
you have to make sure this bishops
trading itself off for the other dark
spread bishop if you allow Knight takes
bishop here you are just absolutely dead
this bishop is never going to leave you
alone and you are gonna be dead dead
lost unfortunately for Danny that's why
I was suggesting here I think Danny had
to play the move Bishop g7 giving up
this pawn on d6 just go down the pond
keep your Kings safe this is devastating
and it's such a sad way to lose a chess
game to such a sad way to lose a chess
game oh I'm so sad about it I'm so sad
this looks so sad we're gonna ignore
this game this game doesn't exist let's
check in on Thalia Thalia put in a lot
of work for the Saint who's chess club
today streaming for quite a few hours
here on the twitch channel what does she
have in this position it looks like she
has a trapped bishop that's not good
[Music]
no their bishops just trapped that
Bishop is just trapped that's
unfortunate
who is her point she seems to be playing
if I can find it here
Bobby enough Bobby enough a 2060 USCF
player seems to be pretty strong in a
rapid though
okay but no Talia was up a piece to
begin with so things are alright here
things are alright black has to retake
the piece now it's it's now or never
it's take it now or be down a piece
forever hold your down a P I don't know
puns are hard so I expect B takes a four
he's probably considering to take back
the C pawn and go for these connected
passed pawns but against the bishops
it's just far too little so I expect P
takes a four and then I think Talia
actually has a nice position c5 is gonna
come on the board and then Talia will
retake on a four it looks like Talia is
up upon in the counts and more
importantly she has this nice passed
pawn on c5 and that's going to tell the
story of the game I think with this pawn
on c5 Talia should be able to push for
the win without too much danger yeah we
did already win we're just going for
extra points here just going for the
extra points okay so if we take on a 493
but simply rook f2 is fine for white I
think she is perfectly safe here if rook
b1 expect rook e to to keep the balance
here and then King f2 is perfectly safe
stepping out of this pin and bringing
the pieces to relative safety King f2
pretty much unstoppable on the next turn
then once again it's all about this C
pawn and Talia should be able to win
this game let's check back in with Luke
Yi who lost a devastating game in severe
time crusher last game stepped into a
camp on end game that ended up to just
barely be losing just barely here it
looks like he has a very strong position
against Nathan with this strong knight
on East
pressure on the black king protected
passed pawn on c5 up upon more active
pieces in a safer King that's a good
recipe to win a chess game so I expect
Lukey to make the most out of this one
and take down his opponent now last game
I got into some time pressure and that
seems to be seems to be his downfall
here in this game as well if black can
find some way to put pressure on the
clock then Lukey might might fall into
some danger for the moment though things
going all right expect to see Luke lifts
this rook lifts this Queen lifts this
rook lifts this rook and then checkmate
somehow it's one of those checkmate
somehow positions I don't know they make
tactical tactics puzzles for this you
don't need me to tell you all right
Jacob wants me to look at his first game
why don't we take a quick pause to do so
it looks like it was a Kings Indian
defense he chooses Bishop g5 uh you know
d5 this is switching to benoni type
stuff
this seems perfectly fine for whites so
far e4 yeah okay I'm fine with you four
takes takes castles no Knight of three
interesting it looks like white might
actually be in a fair bit of trouble
here found some way to not get out of
the pub what went wrong is the question
there were some moves I'm not super
familiar this Bishop g5 one it's not
something I would to play personally I
like just taking the whole center but
here Queen c2 seems normal
c4 is a pretty tricky move to to be
playing pretty tricky move to be playing
and after f4 I think this is where it
all went wrong you don't really want to
open up the opponent's bishop in
Manor you can play moves like Bishop g4
here to get your bishop in the game you
want to trade off in this light squared
bishop perhaps you're not really afraid
of F takes G you'll just play F takes G
yourself in queenside castle and just go
for an attack I think this is the move
that made everything go wrong opening up
the opponent's Bishop like this is
terrifying you also give them a really
great square on e5
so Jacob don't take on f4 in those kinds
of positions that's my advice for you
okay in the meantime Tolly is still
playing Mookie is still playing who else
is still playing Doug is still playing
let's check back in on Doug Doug seems
to have a nice time edge here let me
flip the board and what's going on in
this position Doug is not up any
material but he does have this advantage
on the clock and I think he has an
advantage in peace activity as well so
the move Queen e4 is a check in is
playable here dogs likely considering it
you wouldn't be able to block with f3 do
this Knight hanging so probably came
back to g1 is the best that Y can do and
then from there you can start looking
for ways to to get even further at this
King I would also expect Doug to be
thinking about moves like f5 followed by
f4 it's kind of all about Kings safety
in these end games with major pieces on
the board if you can get at the
opponent's king you are definitely in a
good spot so I like I expect the move f5
now if you can get f4 start to shake
loose this knight shake loose this e to
pawn and shake loose this file in front
of the opponent's king you're going to
have some very nice winning chances the
move sound is a bit loud I apologize I
apologize I don't know if I can turn it
and down I'm going to do some stuff on
the fly here wish me luck wish me luck
I'm opening the volume mixer that's not
gonna do it I know what I should do here
I go
desktop audio turning it way down way
down how is this how is this how is this
sound is this better
hopefully that's better
okay so Doug gave this cheque like I
said I'm expecting the move f5 now from
Doug now dogs a very methodical player a
player who takes his time make sure he
gets things right and I appreciate that
something else Doug might be considering
is perhaps going it for a capture on c4
in some lines I don't like it
immediately and yeah he does play my
move now f5 and once again f4 is the
threat now Rick d1 this is allowing I
think just the simple B takes c4 here
this night cannot move or else Knight f3
check and rook takes d1 comes on the
board so that's a free pawn on c4 for
Doug if he wants it and I I expect he
wants it I mean I want it who doesn't
want it give me that free pawn free pawn
is free and Doug takes it now Queen d2
what is this what is this c3 if nothing
else just c3 c3 is crushing here I think
this is a faulty tactic if you take here
takes here takes takes maybe that's
winning but c3 just looks so crushing it
looks so crushing and soul-crushing
c3 crushes souls the soul crusher
dog needs to pick up the pace a little
bit he finds c3 I love it I love it so
much
that's the type of move that makes you
want to quit chess if you're sterling
here yeah Queen C one simply Knight take
C to check and a fork and that's the
game
sterling resigns good game to Doug he
goes to and OH in the match also notably
we have a few people who went to a no
but let's check in on the remaining
games we're down to those few games that
I had mentioned Dani Machuca is somehow
still holding on Dani Machuca is holding
on when okay all hope is now officially
gone Chiron is just checkmating this
king Dani Machuca falls in the final
moments all right
that just leaves Talia and let's see
Talia and Lukie both of which have very
good positions both of which I expect to
be able to convert Talia has this extra
C pawn and is trying to find some way to
make use of it I think the trick here is
to now start playing on the other side
of the board expect her to play moves
like h4 and rook h3 yet g4 as well you
need to create a threat on the other
side of the board to get things going so
she's actually just bringing the rook
around this also is a way to get active
I would have liked to see a move like
Bishop e1 and then I move like h4 and
move like rook h3 that's I think the way
to go
so she's just playing on the clock a
little bit wow now she breaks with f5
trying to get at these black pawns okay
she gives this check and steps back now
'if i for black you have to take that
pawn okay white now has these two passed
pawns but f5 is falling now d2 is under
threat
this time pressure seems to be getting
the best of Talia now Rick g5 maybe okay
she gives a check I like it okay wait a
second now it's starting to smell like
checkmate
yeah Bishop g5 is a check we can swing
this rook around okay she goes this way
instead now look out though your king is
in some danger Talia your kings and
someday own know what's happening here
the rook falls but the other rook falls
kc6 she's still trying to promote now
okay she's getting on this diagonal
that's good that's good
okay playing on the increment she's
trying to get this rook out of here so
she can get this Bishop on this diagonal
C King d3 King steps back now and it's
looking like this might be a draw or a
loss now for Tolly unfortunately there's
this check but I don't think it's good
okay now if you take Bishop d8 okay this
is a threats she's threatening the rook
again yeah okay I think now yeah it
takes but now Bishop D it should be yeah
there should be a she's winning a piece
but the best she can hope for now is
rook and Bishop against rook she has to
take off these oh she won the rook she
won the rook rook h4 Bishop takes h4
game over good job to Talia crushing her
opponent crushing her opponent that just
leaves the final game of the match here
looky looky to round out the match he
seems to have broken through and is now
killing Nathan's King just filling it
nothing to be done here okay I guess
actually the Queen f7 is a move I didn't
think about Queen f7
Queen f7 if nothing else it's a losing
engine this C pawn is just too strong
Queen f7 you can even just take take
take take take take and this end game is
dead lost expect rookie six and rook
over to 286 and once that pawn falls
it's game set and match
Talia does win that game of course up a
rock in a bishop okay rook takes a fate
now takes on g7 this is matin one Lukey
doesn't Lukie wins the game that brings
the final score of the match to a
devastating 24 214 a 10 point lead over
the mechanics we end up winning this
match I want to give a shout-out to our
notable players justice Williams goes to
an L in his matches vampire chicken
upsets Josiah Wales goes one and a half
out of two Danny Machuca manages to draw
the strong at Chiron Griffith over 2400
USCF player that's a more than 500 point
difference and Danny draws him in round
one who else is notable let's see here
wolf team 2018 I keep forgetting that's
Rachel Leigh Rachel Leigh goes to an O
against an international master what
more can you ask for
Vinnie goes to an O in his matches and
actually scores that crucial 19th point
securing the match victory for us well
done - Vinnie Doug Eckhart also goes to
an O in his games Jacob Sanders - an O
in his games cupcake cupcake goes to an
O as well and secured the tie for us in
the match and the one and only Ben Simon
also going one and a half for - a very
strong showing from the st. Louis team
here and we take down these San
Francisco mechanics well done - st.
Louis alright that's about it nothing
left to do but wrap this up say thank
you to the mechanics for playing of
course I talked a lot of trash in this
stream but we love the opportunity to
play some chess
in this new age that we live in it was a
lot of fun to commentate hopefully you
guys had fun watching and it's great to
see st. Louis continuing to dominate the
online chess scene Shang she also went
one-on-one against someone 400 points
higher rated than him
good job to shengshi as well chess world
scientist I believe is his name so well
done to everybody who played as well
even if he didn't win any games we
appreciate you coming out supporting st.
Louis representing the Chess Club once
again it was a lot of fun thank you guys
so much for joining us and be sure to
stay tuned tomorrow when we continue to
give you guys the best chess content we
can that's all for me tonight thank